[Music]
hello there it's time to look at video
games dropping in August the games
industry begins to fire so many games
our way it's tough to know what's worth
your time so like always I found a bunch
of full price AAA juggernauts a
spattering of reduced price experiences
and a few free games to tide you over
today's video is sponsored by Focus
entertainment and a game I've been
looking forward to for a very long time
now August 2023 new games let's do this
hell yeah I'm starting with Atlas Fallen
because visually it looks amazing deck
13's third person action role-playing
game Atlas Fallen begins with creating
our own character one of the many
nameless in the land but a chance
encounter with this magic Gauntlet
changes everything this thing can
manipulate sand and that's why we see
the cool sand surfing traversal mechanic
we haven't seen since 2012's Journey our
new goal is to free mankind from the
corrupted gods that watch over the world
the further we progress the more ability
is we unlock and the more our weapons
evolve and that's when the legendary
creatures face us unique beasts with
unique fighting styles but rest assured
all do have weaknesses but we have to
find them so combat looks to have an
additional level of strategy and who can
turn down a fight with a dragon for
context this is most definitely not a
souls-like game it's all about action
and Grandeur and there's an extra cherry
on top of this it may look like a solo
game and it sure can be played that way
but it's also possible to play this with
a friend drop in Dropout Co-op from
start to end Atlas Fallen has a great
deal of potential releasing on August
10th on Playstation Xbox and PC
next up is the Immortals of avian a
first person shooter but there isn't a
gun in sight to fit the fantasy setting
we instead wield magic through our hands
we play as Jack who joins a battle mage
order to save the planet from
Annihilation he somehow has the ability
to wield three magic types which is rare
in this universe the three types are
color-based red blue and green and
represent destruction manipulation and
life force but more realistically we can
generally sum these core abilities up
like this the red is like a short range
shotgun blast the blue acts like a long
range sniper rifle and the green is this
mid-range lmg another cool mechanic is
the whip that we hold which has the
ability to lasso enemies to bring them
closer to your red weapon it goes deeper
than that but overall that's the basic
premise of the magic abilities you'll
also need to upgrade the talent tree to
unlock and evolve your powers Immortals
of AVM is a terrible name for a video
game but it releases on August 22nd on
PS5 Xbox series and PC
have a look at armored Core 6 which is
getting huge attention as it's the next
game from the developers behind Eldon
ring and you're not seeing things
armored Core 6 is a mech-based combat
game we are told that this version of
armored Core is like a soft reboot to
the series designed to help new players
jump in without any knowledge at all our
Mech is customizable over time as we
prepare to fight bosses and their
minions and from software have confirmed
the game will be challenging as seen in
the recent Elden ring and sakuro games a
stagger mechanic is confirmed which is
going to be the core of the battles it's
not an open world but each mission is
created as large as possible to give
players choice of any direction to
Traverse we're still waiting on real
meaty info which should be coming in the
next few weeks armored Core 6 fires of
Rubicon releases on August 25th on PS4
PS5 the Xboxes and PC
[Music]
there's a lot of love for asymmetric
multiplayer games like Dead by daylight
and Friday the 13th games where one
person plays as the overpowered bad guy
and a team of survivors attempt to
outsmart them and escape unharmed this
time the movie franchise Texas Chainsaw
Massacre is trying out the genre I can't
show too much as I'd like to stay on
YouTube's good graces but rest assured
it's a gruesome horror game four
captured survivors must work together to
misdirect the hungry cannibals and Get
Out Alive inevitably Leatherface will be
near chainsaw in hand if this sounds
like your game look out for it on August
18th on Playstation Xbox and PC
[Music]
okie dokie let's look at free games this
month and wow there's a bunch Tower of
fantasy is my pick as it makes its debut
on PlayStation 4 and 5 this month the
open world action RPG which definitely
takes inspiration from breath of the
Wild and the Behemoth free-to-play game
Genji impact the anime style MMO has a
surprisingly good story that builds the
lore of the planet the real wow factor
is exploration searching this open world
finding unexpected NPCs battles and
items for combat it's real time and we
select three weapons to take along with
us and we switch them out on the fly to
find a weakness against our foes one
thing I really like is the perfect Dodge
mechanic which briefly freezes your
enemy in place for a few seconds for
uncontested damage character
customization is deep as we make our
perfect Avatar and as this is an MMO you
shouldn't meet anyone who looks
identical to you Tower of fantasy is
already available on PC and comes to
PlayStation for free on August 8th
another free game recently released is
naraka blade point the XBox exclusive
unexpectedly became free to play and
released on PlayStation 5 last week a
battle royale game unlike its peers
naraka's focus is melee combat as 60
players face off to be the last
surviving the martial arts inspired
combat uses a rock paper scissors
approach but there are occasional ranged
weapons and a great grappling hook to
get around the map quickly the board in
between battles is usually the downfall
of most battle royales so this grappling
hook will really help that issue naraka
blade point is out right now totally
free on PS5 Xbox and PC
[Music]
and speaking of games that quietly
switch to a free-to-play model Divine
knockout is now free the platform
fighter set in third person was
initially seen on PS plus but that
decision has been reversed in a very
cartoony style we take control of a god
ranging from Nast Legends like Loki and
Thor to Greek myths like Zeus and Athena
and even King Arthur is playable and a
cool touch is that characters are ranked
on how easy they are to pick up and play
Divine knockout has a small but
dedicated Community who really need new
blood so you can play it right now for
free on Playstation 4 5 the Xboxes and
PC and you don't need PS Plus or Games
with Gold oh and a quick note about
another game which is touted as free to
play but it's releasing in August in
Early Access for people who've paid for
a Founders pack this is wayfinder an MMO
of sorts in which we play as a wayfinder
exploring dungeons hunting beasts and
constantly crafting and upgrading
weapons and armor I'll be buying
wayfinder on August 15th and I'll tell
you about it before it releases for free
later in 2023
[Music]
free stuff back to back tipped games and
reduced price game to be specific a few
months back I showed you wrestle quests
but typically a day later it was delayed
to August I'm hoping that doesn't happen
again now wrestle Quest takes the
concept of pro wrestling and turns it
into a retro fantasy RPG we go on an
adventure and become the best in the
world we undertake storylines that
result in a matchup against WWF Legends
and on Victory gets the respect you need
I'm lucky looking forward to this August
8th on the PlayStations the Xboxes the
PC and the switch too there are so many
more games coming this month that I
haven't had chance to talk about like
Fort Solis a psychological Thriller set
on Mars presented like a Netflix TV
series Troy Baker and red dead 2's Roger
clack are involved in the game and we're
still waiting on previews to see what
it's really like the addictive family
Co-op moving game gets a sequel moving
out to we are in charge of removals
getting household items and placing them
carefully on the truck it quickly
becomes apparent that destruction is a
legit method to moving house quickly
under the waves is another narrative
driven Adventure game which looks at
isolation and how it changes the State
of Mind of Stan here whilst he has this
very unique job August 29th for that one
another one of Xbox's exclusive games
has now arrived on Playstation high on
life the comedy shooter is out right now
it just released suddenly overnight and
goodbye Volcano High the furry Coming of
Age game gets a release in August and
finally Baldur's Gate 3 looks to be a
very impressive role-playing game with
turn-based combat the PlayStation
released was delayed to September so I'm
going to talk about it next month
instead if that's okay and as there are
so many new games coming out this month
if you think I've missed one and it
needs more attention let me know and
I'll show to double back on it next
month anyway what are you playing this
month I'm gonna jump into Atlas fallen
and I think Tower of fantasy is worth a
try your reward for staying to the end
of the video is a few dad jokes I
apologize in advance but that does
remind me of a time when I found a
wooden shoe in the toilet yeah it was
clogged
oh and scientists say there aren't 26
letters in the alphabet anymore there's
only 25. I don't know why
sorry about that come on I'm Adam you're
awesome it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time